the onset of the covert 19 pandemic has
brought about a new digital revolution
having said that this also has been a
catalyst for the increase in the number
of cyber crimes across the globe
to keep cyber crimes in check and
safeguard crucial data organizations are
on the lookout for cyber security
professionals now more than ever
there is a dearth of cyber security
professionals compared to the number of
job opportunities in this field
so what better than starting a career in
cyber security
here we are to help you with that
get prepared to start your cyber
security career with us
simply learn skill up provides the best
introduction to the lucrative field of
cyber security the best part about it is
that it is free
yes you can start your cybersecurity
learning journey free of cost and get a
course completion certificate for the
same
let me take you through the details of
our free cybersecurity basics course
simply learn skill up course on
introduction to cyber security targets
beginners who aspire to become cyber
security professionals
here we will acquaint you with cyber
security from scratch
the topics covered in this course are
cyber security fundamentals mitigation
network security controls byod security
testing is governance risk management
incident management and disaster
recovery to name a few this program
helps you get acquainted with the
current cyber security structure and
relevant security tools
the course is three hours long and all
the modules in it are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
entire course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace anytime anywhere
after completing this course you are
awarded a course completion certificate
by simply learn
this certificate can be shared within
your professional circle so now you
might be thinking who is eligible to
take up this course right
well there are no prerequisites to
enroll in this course each of you who
has a zeal for learning cyber security
can take up this course irrespective of
your experience
experienced industry experts have
specially designed this well-structured
beginner's course to enable a smooth
learning journey
skillup's introductory course is also
recommended for those who have some
knowledge of cyber security but are
looking to reskill and upskill
themselves with the critical cyber
security concepts
this course also caters to management
professionals security consultants and
security engineers
this cyber security course helps you
carry out business impact analysis and
disaster recovery testing
so what are you waiting for head
straight to our skill up page and enrich
your cyber security knowledge by
enrolling in our free introduction to
cyber security
course certifications bring you one step
closer to your dreams and what can get
better than a free certificate to
strengthen your profile
back the opportunity and become a cyber
security expert today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here